grâce à ce conseil national où nous
sommes tous réunis
j'en ai la conviction l'efficacité le
pragmatisme et la responsabilité vont
bien être au coeur à présent de la
politique pour nos concitoyens
rien n'est impossible si nous savons
nous rassembler avec toutes nos
différences
c'est le coeur de mon engagement alors
ce premier conseil national de l'année
est l'occasion pour nous de nous
rassembler autour de françois fillon
avec pour seul but et seul objectif de
le conduire à la victoire et de lui
apporter la majorité présidentielle
nécessaires pour mener à terme nos
réformes les landes ne sont plus une
terre démission mais une terre de
conquête pour la droite et le centre
et nous allons le prouver dans les
échéances qui suivent les
présidentielles et les législatives
je me suis engagé auprès des
républicains parce que je crois que nous
avons à restaurer dans notre pays la
confiance
l'audace et l' envie de construire
ensemble une nation forte une france
puissante qui a encore beaucoup de
choses à dire au monde
ensemble nous allons créer un large
rassemblement autour de notre candidat
françois fillon et le conseil national
de cette belle journée doit être le
moment fondateur pour tous nous mettre
au service de notre candidat et faire
gagner françois fillon en mai prochain
et lui offrir en juin une majorité
franche une majorité loyal une majorité
claire qui permettra de faire les
réformes dont notre pays a tant besoin
à partir de 2017
[Musique]